HENRY.
♪
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW WITH
MORE REACTION TO TONIGHT'S
FORMER DEPUTY ASSISTANT TO
THE PRESIDENT AND FOX NEWS
NATIONAL SECURITY STRATEGIST
SEBASTIAN GORKA AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR HERMAN CAIN, YOU
KNOW, DR. GORKA, THINK OF
WHAT WE HAD A WEEK AGO TODAY
WE GOT THE HOUSE INTEL, THE
NUNES MEMO.
THEN WE GOT THE SENATE MEMO
ON MONDAY.
THEN WE GOT THE UNREDACTED
VERSION ON TUESDAY.
THEN WE FOINSD OUT THAT THE
URANIUM ONE INFORMANT
TESTIFIED BEFORE THREE
COMMITTEES IN WASHINGTON THE
GREAT IRONY HERE IS THAT
THE ELECTION.
AND THAT'S HILLARY PAYING
FOR RUSSIAN LIES THAT THEN
GETS USED AS A FOUNDATION
FOR A FISA WARRANT AND THAT
WE KNEW 18 MONTHS IN ADVANCE
OF BRIBERY, EXTORTION, MONEY
LAUNDERING KICK BACKS BY
PUTIN OPERATIVES IN AMERICA.
AND WE STILL ALLOWED HIM TO
GET 20% OF AMERICA'S
URANIUM.
AND THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
STILL STUCK ON TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION WITH NO EVIDENCE.
>> RIGHT, SEAN.
SO IF YOU WANT TO SEE
CHAPTER AND VERSE, JUST GO
TO PETER SCHWEIZER'S BOOK OR
WATCH THE FREE VIDEO ONLINE
ON YOUTUBE.
CLINTON CASH DOCUMENTS ALL
OF, THIS WHETHER IT'S
URANIUM ONE, WHETHER IT'S
HAITI, WHETHER IT'S ALL THE
CORRUPTION THAT'S CONNECTED
TO HOW THIS WOMAN AND HER
THEIR LIFE.
NUMBER ONE, IT'S ALL LAID
OUT THERE.
LET'S LOOK AT THE RECENT
CHARGES AND THE RECENT
THINGS THAT WE HAVE LEARNED
FROM DEVIN AND FROM SENATOR
GRASSLEY.
YOU KNOW, THE MOVIES,
CONSTANT REFERENCES.
WHAT WAS WATERGATE?
ALLEGEDLY THE BIGGEST
POLITICAL SCANDAL IN MODERN
TIMES IN AMERICAN, WHICH IS
ABOUT THE COVER UP, JUST THE
COVER UP OF ONE BUNGLED
BURGLARY.
NOT ONE EVENT AND THE
COVERUP.
WE HAVE A SYSTEMATIC
WEAPONIZATION OF FEDERAL
IT'S THE IRS.
IT'S THE DOJ.
IT IS, AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
AND LOOK AT THE TRAIL OF
BODIES ALREADY WHAT IS IT
>> UP TO 8TH.
DEMOTED FIRED OR RETIRED.
>> OR MOVED ON.
ALREADY.
THIS IS, PERHAPS, THE
INFLEXION POINT.
I AM WAITING FOR THOSE FBI
AGENTS, THOSE ANALYSTS,
THOSE DOJ EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE
BEEN SUFFERING IN SILENCE,
WHO HAVE BEEN AFRAID BUT NOW
THERE IS A POINT WHERE THEY
SEE IT'S GOING TO COME OUT.
SO, GET IN FRONT OF IT NOW,
AND TELL US WHAT YOU KNOW.
>> Sean: WELL, I KNOW MANY
OF THE RANK AND FILE ARE.
AND WE HAVE GONE TO GREAT
PAINS ON THIS PROGRAM TO
MAKE SURE OUR AUDIENCE
UNDERSTANDS.
THIS IS NOT RANK AND FILE
FBI.
INTELLIGENCE.
THIS IS THOUGHT RANK AND
FILE OF THE DOJ.
THIS IS THE UPPER ECHELON.
DON'T SEE A BIGGER ABUSE OF
POWER CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN
OUR HISTORY AS BIG AS THIS
ONE.
>> NEITHER HAVE I.
THIS IS THE ABSOLUTE
BIGGEST.
I COMMEND YOU AND YOUR STAFF
FOR CONTINUING TO REPORT THE
FACTS AND CONNECT THE DOTS.
THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT
SOME LAWS HAVE BEEN BROKEN.
BUT DUE PROCESS TAKES TIME.
SOMEBODY SHOULD GO TO JAIL.
AND ALL ROADS LEAD TO THE
TIME BEFORE ALL OF THE DOTS
ARE CONNECTED.
WHEN THERE WAS A COVERUP AS
DR. GORKA TALKED ABOUT,
THAT'S ONE THING.
AND WHEN IT WAS EXPOSED, IT
WAS OUT THERE ALMOST
SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION OR
CANDIDATE TRUMP AND HIS
PEOPLE.
NOW WE KNOW IT WASN'T.
IT WAS THE DEMOCRATS, THE
CLINTONS, AND IT WAS ALL
ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON
CAMPAIGN.
>> Sean: ISN'T THAT THE MOST
IRONIC THING HERE?
>> YES.
>> Sean: IT'S A GREAT IRONY.
LOOK AT THE GRAHAM-GRASSLEY
MEMO.
IT'S NOT ONLY RUSSIA.
THEY TALKED ABOUT RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT LIES.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: FED TO STEELE THAT
THEN IS USED UNVERIFIED BY
ANYBODY TO GET A FISA
WARRANT.
I MEAN, AND THE URANIUM ONE
DEAL.
SAME THING.
THEY KNEW ABOUT CLINTON,
PUTIN OPERATIVES IN THIS
COUNTRY.
ROBERT MUELLER WAS THE FBI
WE WILL TALK ABOUT IT IN THE
NUMBER ONE, IT'S PERVERSION
ANYBODY WATCHING THIS TV
SHOW.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, WHEN
IS THIS ILLEGAL SPYING
HAPPENING?
SO WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
GIVING THE FBI PURE TAINTED
INFORMATION TO GET THAT
WARRANT.
CONSTITUTIONAL ORDER.
>> Sean: YEAH.
YOU KNOW, HERMAN CAIN, WHAT
I'M HOPING FOR HERE IS THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT IF WE GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF IT, IF THIS
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT
COMING OUT IN A COUPLE WEEKS
IS ALL WE EXPECT IT IS ALL
GO BACK TO HILLARY CLINTON
WAS PROTECTED AND WHERE ANY
OTHER AMERICAN WOULD HAVE
GOTTEN ARRESTED BECAUSE WE
HAVE A SPECIAL CATEGORY FOR
THE CLINTONS AND THERE WAS A
MASSIVE RIGGING OF THE CRIME
SHE COMMITTED -- PEOPLE SAID
WHY ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
CLINTON, HANNITY?
IF WE DID THE THINGS SHE DID
DELETE SUBPOENAED EMAILS AND
PUTTING IT IN MOM AND SHOP
BATHROOM CLOSET AND USING
BLEACH BIT AND HAMMERS I
THINK WE WOULD ALL BE
ARRESTED.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE WILL GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
IT BECAUSE THE MORE AND MORE
REWE VEAL WHAT THE FACTS ARE